une prise de parole initialement prévu
pour permettre à emmanuel macron
d'évoquer les dernières réformes de son
quinquennat avant l'élection
présidentielle
mais la crise sanitaire change la donne
l'épidémie redémarre en france en raison
du variant delta désormais majoritaire
le conseil scientifique appel à de
nouvelles mesures pour éviter une
quatrième vague
le chef de l'état s'exprimera ce soir
dans le cadre d'une allocution ce matin
il a présidé un nouveau conseil de
défense
les détails de notre reporter david
khalifa aux abords de l'elysée
rien n'a filtré à l'issue de ce conseil
de défense sanitaire exceptionnelle qui
a débuté à 10 heures et s'est achevée
vers 11h30 un conseil de défense
sanitaire présidée par emmanuel macron
le président qui est une nouvelle fois
été rattrapé par le corona à virus son
allocution de ce soir tournera
essentiellement sur le co vide et 19
plusieurs sujets brûlants d'abord la
situation épidémique en france
olivier ferrand a été éclair hier les
chiffres de contamination repartent à la
hausse et devrait continuer d'augmenter
d'ici les prochaines semaines due aux
variants un delta le ministre de la
santé dresse un bilan assez alarmant
écouter ce que je constate en france et
que les hospitalisations ont arrêté de
baisser depuis 24-48 heures par ailleurs
on enregistre une petite hausse de
l'activité de sos médecins notamment en
ile-de-france qui montre que l'épidémie
est effectivement en train de repartir
avec la tendance épidémique de ce
variant delta qui est beaucoup plus
contagieux que le coc vie 19 auquel nous
avions affaire avait été dernier les
3000 cas pourrait devenir 6000 cas dans
une semaine
douze mille cas dans quinze jours est
monté au dessus de 20 mille voire plus
début août
si nous n'agissons pas alors en quoi
consistent ces actions concrètement
d'abord l'extension du pass est
sanitaire qui devrait se traduire par la
diminuation jauge dans les salles de
spectacles plusieurs lieux n'exige pas
le pass annie terre pour pouvoir accéder
il devrait maintenant s'y soumettre on
parle et des salles de restaurants des
salles de sport bien encore lvl cinéma
d'autre part les territoires les plus
touchés par le variant deltas pourraient
faire l'objet de nouvelles restrictions
un sanitaire puis les tests pcr sous les
recommandations du conseil
y'a scientifique le gouvernement devrait
rendre payant les tests pcr dits de
confort afin d'inciter à la vaccination
un tour de vis à des frontières devrait
également être abordée par emmanuel
macron mais la mesure principale qui
devraient être annoncées c est la
vaccination obligatoire pour tous les
soignants un projet de loi est en cours
de rédaction il devrait être déposé au
conseil d'état cette semaine avant
d'être présenté en conseil des ministres
le 21 juillet prochain
le secrétaire d'état chargé des affaires
européennes n'a pas caché les intentions
de l'exécutif écouter aujourd'hui c'est
une hypothèse très probable est légitime
il y à des concertations depuis
plusieurs jours avec les professionnels
de santé et les élus locaux sur ce point
spécifique
la potentielle obligation vaccinale pour
les personnels soignants
notre première obligation était de
donner accès au vaccin ça fait plus de
six mois
les soignants ont été publics
prioritaires ils l'ont bien fait mais
certains ont attendu ont eu des doutes à
savoir que le texte pourrait être
élargie à plusieurs catégories
professionnelles qui sont en contact
directement avec des personnes
vulnérables
est-ce qui a fait suite à une
recommandation de la haute autorité de
santé la question de sanctions
financières en cas de refus est
également à l'étude un selon les mots de
mpm embaument en tout cas vous l'aurez
compris la locution des modèles macron
tournera essentiellement autour du corps
la bis rue ce soir même elle s'y est le
chef d'état devrait aborder brièvement
l'avenir à moins d'un an de la fin de
son quinquennat avec notamment en ligne
de mire l'épineuse question de la
réforme des retraites